وفي الاثناء قال رئيس مركز التدريب
القتالي في الجيش الروسي في غيني اربيلون
انا روسيا شكرت مجموعات عسكريه لتدمير
الدبابات القادمه من الغرب الى اوكرانيا
الى ان تشكيله هذه المجموعات كان باعاز من
نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي مضيفا ان هناك
خطه وضعت لتنفيذها على ارض الواقع
معنى الان من دونيات مراسلنا بابا ولد
حرمه ومن كياف مراسلات مراسلنا عفوا تامر
الصمادي بابا وتامر اهلا بكما وابدا معك
تامر الصمادي حدثنا عن اخر المواقف من
كييف تفضل
المواقف السياسيه ليله متواصله لا سيما
على لسان الرئيس الاوكراني زالنسكي الذي
تحدث عن نتائج زيارته الى بولندا الى
وارسو وقال بان الاليات العسكريه من
بولندا متواجده في الميدان تقاتل على اهبه
الاستعداد وان هنالك ايضا كميات اخرى من
السلاح
والمدرعات ستصل تباعا وايضا وجه دعوته
للقاده قاده العالم لسيما في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الناتو وايضا الولايات
المتحده بضروره الاسراع في المضي بارسال
مزيد من المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا من
اجل مواصله القتال وقال بان الفتره
المقبله سوف تكون حاسمه مهمه للقوات
الاوكرانيه على طول الجبهات والحديث هنا
بالتاكيد عن الشرق والجنوب في المقابل
الميدانيه نتطورات العسكريه تتواصل في شرق
البلاد وفي جنوبها القصف الروسي ايضا
يتواصل لابدا من الجنوب الحديث من الصباح
هذا اليوم عن كان هنالك قصف متواصل للقوات
الروسيه على المناطق المهوله بالسكان وفقا
للاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه هناك الحديث
عن ثلاثه قتله وخمسه جرحى في صفوف
المدنيين ودمار كبير في البنيه التحتيه
وفي المنازل المنازل المدنيه التي اخليت
في الحقيقه في من كثير من سكان لاسيما عند
نقاط التماس ايضا التطورات كانت في خرسون
هنالك قصف متواصل على المدينه وفقا
للاداره العسكريه هناك جنوبي البلاد
الحديث عن اكثر من 70 هجوما طيله الليله
الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم باكثر من 500
قذيفه سقطت على عديد المواقع المواقع
البنيه التحتيه وفي المقابل تحدثت قياده
عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه عن ان السلطات
والقوات الروسيه
تعظم وتزيد من النشر الامدادات والحواجز
ايضا على الضفه اليمنى من نهر د تتواجد
القوات الروسيه هناك وذلك تحسبا لاي
عمليات جديده للقوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
مواقع القوات الروسيه لكن المتحدثه باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب ايضا تحدثت بان
القياده الاوكرانيه في الجنوب تدخل في
مرحله صمت عن اي مواقف تتعلق بتطورات
الميدان بانها لن تعلن عن اي تفاصيل الا
عندما تنجز هذه العمليات كما وصفتها وكما
قالت وفي التطور الاكبر والاهم والابرز في
الميدان وهو وهي المعارك الاشرس في باق
موت كانت هنالك تصريحات مهمه لهيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه صباح هذا اليوم قالت
بان القوات الروسيه ما زالت تتقدم تحاول
الوصول الى مواقع اضافيه لكنها قالت بان
الامور تحت السيطره وفقا للبيان السيطره
الاوكرانيه هو بان القتال مستمر ويستعر
وايضا تحدثت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
في هذا السياق وقالت بان الامور صعبه في
باخموت لكن القتال كما قالت متواصل
والعمليات التي وصفتها بالفاشله للقوات
الروسيه في الضياف كمارينكا ايضا تتواصل
وتخضع للصد من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه نعم
اشكرك